author of and we just found out tonight
debuting as the number one New York
Times best seller triggered how the left
thrives on hate and once the silence I
see is the executive vice president of
the Trump Organization Donald Trump jr.
all right so your dad you do a number
one bestseller art of the deal
right yeah anyone else in the family of
any number one bestsellers I don't know
my dad may have had a couple so I
probably have to write a few more books
shown to catch up but I'm pretty happy
where we are right now thank you all
right before we get to the madness
you've been experience out on the road
which has been highly entertaining to
watch from a distance that I mean that
from a distance what was your reaction
everything today because I thought it
was a ship show it really was I mean
I've never seen anything more ridiculous
you see exactly what America voted
against in 2016
career government bureaucrats doing
their thing there's no fact base
everything was hearsay I heard it from a
friend who heard it from a friend who
heard it from a friend I'm saying this
is a joke I mean this is their lead Sean
and then I heard the Democrats and this
is when you realize how bad or frankly
non-existent their cases well hearsay is
oftentimes much better than regular
evidence I'm saying that guys say that
with a straight face like during the
halls of Congress yeah hearsay meaning
like the telephone game that we learned
about in kindergarten is better than
actual direct evidence so it's better to
have heard it from a friend who heard it
from a friend who heard it from a friend
than to have heard it with your own ears
I mean that's the level of insanity that
you're seeing from these bureaucrats
who've taken anti-trump position they're
being you know led badgered and bullied
by shift to give them what they want
because the mainstream media will carry
their water and function as the
marketing wing of the Democrat Party
they'll say whatever it is just to get
out of there when the Republicans start
questioning Adam Schiff changes the
rules changes the goal posts pretends
that they can't even ask that question
anymore it's never-ending I mean it's a
comedy at this point it's so ridiculous
and it's exactly what the American
people have needed to see because if you
didn't buy a
first time if you didn't buy the second
time with all the hoaxes with Russia
version one two and all the collusion
nonsense
we heard about that was gospel it was
fact for three years you're gonna
believe it this time Sean because this
time that's different
give me a break it's insanity so so you
get two different visuals today because
you have president air DeWanna Turkey
really important stuff going on with
your dad
that's happening at the same time the
ship show is going on and I'm thinking
okay so you got the president record low
unemployment best unemployment situation
since nineteen sixty-nine record low
unemployment for every demographic and
then I think okay name one thing
Democrats have done to help can't be
more safe or secure create jobs that
make us more prosperous I can't think of
one not one thing that they have one
watching not one person watching can
name one thing that the Democrats have
done in the year that they've had the
house not one thing to make us safer not
one thing to move us forward the u.s.
MCA Shawn the renegotiation of NAFTA the
thing that everyone said would never be
able to be renegotiated my father did it
he got it done because she is a
negotiator unlike all of these clowns in
Congress who are just bureaucrats he
renegotiated with Canada with Mexico
they're in agreement and it's been
sitting on Nancy Pelosi's desk for nine
months it would create north of a
hundred thousand jobs for Americans
bring the jobs and the American dream
that we've done nothing but export bring
that back so Americans can live it but
because it would also give Trump a win
let's not vote on it you know it would
pass with flying colors with bipartisan
support but she won't bring it up
because she wants to make sure that
Trump doesn't get any additional credit
despite all of the things he's already
done for America that's the level of
hatred that you see from the left
they're not looking to govern they're
not looking to do anything they're
looking to try to resist because they
know they can't beat Trump in the polls
they're gonna try to impeach and it's
not gonna work in the long run and the
American people see through it show and
they're sick of this garbage they're a
quick last ten seconds did your dad
had here yet about you be number one
debuting number one on the New York
Times list he did it he was surprised as
I was frankly because you know we've
heard a lot about conservative writers
getting sort of blocked or banned or
prevented from being there so I'll give
him this they did the right thing that
once they did I know they I was number
one got their good luck congratulations